مره جديده تعرضت مدينه خاركيف الاوكرانيه
لقصف صاروخي روسي صباح الاثنين مما ادى
الى تدمير منشات سكنيه وصناعيه واصابه عده
اشخاص رئيس بلديه خاركيف ثاني اكبر مدن
اوكرانيا قال ان صواريخ اس 300 الروسيه
اصابت مدينه خاركيف مرتين وعمت الانذارات
من غارات جويه انحاء اوكرانيا اعتبارا من
الساعه السادسه صباحا بالتوقيت
المحلي سقطت الصواريخ بالقرب من منازل
خاصه في احد احياء المدينه اصيبت امراه
واحده على الاقل المنشات الصناعيه تعرضت
للقصف مما ادى الى نشوب
حريق القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه قالت ان
البلاد تتعرض لعده موجات من القصف مضيفه
بانها تصدت لما يقرب من نصف الصواريخ
الروسيه التي استهدفت اوكرانيا حتى الان
في وقت تواجه مدن كرفير وزبرو جيا وخك
ونيبرو تروسك هجوما صاروخيا كبيرا وتقع
خاركيف بالقرب من الحدود مع روسيا وغير
بعيد عن بجرود التي وعدت موسكو بالرد على
هجمات صاروخيه اوكرانيه استهدفت المدينه
في الاونه الاخيره في نفس السياق اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان انظمه دفاعها
الجوي اعترضت صاروخا اوكرانيا من طراز اس
200 فوق مقاطعه بالقروض وذلك بعد ان تم
تعديله لاصابه اهداف ارضيه l